[Music]
hello and welcome to trigonometry I'm
Francis Foster i'm konstantine kitchen
and this is the show for you if you want
honest conversations with fascinating
people brilliant and very fascinating
guest today is Megan Murphy who's an
independent journalist and writer and
youtuber now as well Megan welcome to
trigonometry hey thanks for having me on
it is a pleasure to have you on and
listen for anyone who doesn't know who
you are just tell everybody a little bit
about who are you how are you where you
are and what is the journey that brings
you here talking to us I'm Megan Murphy
as we've established I'm a writer and
I've been running a website called
feminist current which is a feminist
website since like 2012 so I've done
like a lot of writing around feminism
I've been podcasting for a long time and
as you mentioned I recently got some
stuff going on my YouTube channel mainly
because I kind of wanted to explore
issues outside of feminism and talk to
people that maybe were we're a little
less like me talk to some people that I
wasn't accustomed to speaking with in
the past which I've been really enjoying
trying to kind of branch out I also do
freelance work so I realize writing I
should say for the spectator and unheard
mostly these days it's good to have a
fellow Nazi in the conversation
fantastic but one of the things that I
think brought you to prominence in many
people's eyes and I imagine you'd be
quite tired of talking about it but you
just so that people are aware you have
been banned from Twitter permanently for
misgendering someone is that right no I
didn't mess gender anyone specifically I
they started kind of locking down my
account and combing through my tweets
and one of the tweets that they locked
me down for was men are not
women which is believed like a criminal
statement and and for asking what's the
difference between I think I asked what
was the difference between a trans woman
and a man and I wasn't
I actually really wasn't trying to be
antagonistic although you know I I do
like to you know joke and poke at people
but I'm also you know just being
straightforward and what I was trying to
get at was like what is it that happens
between being a male and becoming a
trans woman you know what are we saying
when we're saying someone as a trans
woman because nobody seems to be able to
answer these questions like what is the
difference between on Wednesday you're a
male and on Thursday you're a trans
woman what happened there did you change
your outfit you just sort of feel like
womanly on the inside you're feeling a
little emotional I don't know I was
gonna say you take a pay cut but no
that's a good one too and like so yeah
so they locked my account down for that
one and then what finally they they
permanently banned me for was a
reference to a man named Jonathan Yaniv
who had taken a number of female
aestheticians here in the Vancouver area
I live in Vancouver - we filed human
rights complaints against them because
they wouldn't give him a Brazilian
bikini wax and he claimed that this was
transphobic discrimination because he is
in fact female and therefore his [ __ ]
and balls are lady [ __ ] and balls and I
he his name was under a publication ban
so at the time the media were not
printing his name they were referring to
him as JY and somebody discovered his
real identity I tweeted something saying
like is it true that jy is in fact so
and so linking to his Twitter account
and it was it was proved to be so
somebody sent me a screenshot and it was
a
like screenshot you know as his name his
face he was leaving a review on Yelp or
something like that saying like Britney
did a great job on my Brazilian bikini
wax and so I responded I posted that
screenshot and said yeah it's him that's
all I said yeah it's him and then I was
permanently banned so I mean I guess you
could call it misgendering except that
he was still using his male pronouns in
various places online including on
social media so he was misgendering
himself which means that he should have
been banned from social media for
transphobic hate crimes against himself
I think and Megan oh like this issue has
now become very much into the mainstream
and I've got you know you talk about it
normally in a hushed tones looking over
your shoulder as because that's the way
it is and a lot of men don't get it they
don't see what the big deal is they
don't see what the fuss is could you
just explain to people why this is such
an important issue not only for you but
also for women well I mean first of all
I think that it's important that we be
allowed to discuss material reality and
to tell the truth and also to engage in
debate around contentious topics so you
know regardless of whether or not this
this you know I mean III don't think
that what I'm saying is particularly
offensive I'm saying males cannot change
sex it's biologically impossible that's
I'm not saying that to be cruel or
judgmental it's just true and I mean I
don't actually think that it's very
helpful to go around telling people that
it's possible to change their sex
because I think that they'll be sorely
disappointed when they realize that's
not the case but you know in general we
should be able to have conversations if
you if you literally think that a man
should be able to declare himself a
woman then explain to me why why is that
important why would a man ever need to
declare himself a woman um but moreover
of course you know if if men can be
women just by saying so then that means
that they have access to any and all
female spaces so that means
you know women and girls change rooms
wellness transition houses they can be
transferred to female prisons they can
compete in sports against women which
are all really problematic areas you
know we we know that men are physically
different than women we know that men
are in general stronger than women and
you know we're seeing now men competing
against women in like track and field
and winning and in like rugby and like
weightlifting competitions and I mean
it's ridiculous but it's also like okay
then that's the end of female sports I
guess I mean women can't compete fairly
if they have to compete against men so
if we're gonna have you know like rights
and spaces for women we have to be able
to define what a woman is and if a man
is a woman then we can't there's no such
thing as a woman if like literally
anything and anyone is a woman just
because they say so I mean this an
interesting point you make and we wanted
to talk to you about feminism in detail
and it kind of towards the second half
of the interview but I think it's
important to bring it up here because
you talked about you know you want to be
able to discuss reality you want to
understand that men and women are
different that men tend to be bigger
stronger faster and there's all kinds of
other differences right but some people
might say that feminists some feminists
not all feminists but some feminists
have been eroding the concept of reality
in over the last 20 or 30 years
pretending that these differences don't
exist you know France has made a joke
about the gender pay gap a lot of
evidence now is it doesn't really exist
in the way that people talk about it
right so do you think that there's some
responsibility that feminists need to
take for introducing this erosion of
reality into the into the entire public
space sure I mean I do think that it's a
mistake to pretend that men and women
are equal and I don't think that it's
necessary and by equal I mean literally
equal like of course we should have the
same access to human rights and the same
access to we should be treated with
respect and dignity and be safe from
they've been protected from
discrimination and violence but men and
women aren't the same and pretending
that they are and pushing for that is
you know unnecessary in my opinion and
yeah I think I'm sure there's lots of
places along the way that feminists have
made a mistake and in many ways those
who probably would describe themselves
as feminists in Gender Studies
departments in academia are are
responsible for this new gender identity
ideology that we're dealing with now
we're you know how you feel on the
inside
defines your body and defines material
reality I mean that's all kind of as far
as I can tell most of that came out of
gender studies queer studies this idea
that you can kind of subvert reality
through language or imagination and
isn't it just a one-stop way to actually
make yourself feel incredibly miserable
as well is if you deny that there's no
difference between the genders and in a
sense denying you know some aspects of
being male which are important you know
which are important for men and by going
oh that's unimportant
all of a sudden you take away something
inherent in us I mean at the end of the
day I really just want everyone to be
able to be themselves and so you know
like I differentiate between sex and
gender so when I talk about sex I'm
talking about the body whether or not
you're born male or female and when I
talk about gender I'm talking about
femininity and masculinity so that's
more attached to the stereotypes around
behaviors and likes and dislikes maybe
things like clothing
Megan sorry to drug but just for anyone
who's listening but just an ordinary
person who's not engaged to know any of
these conversations I just explained
that to people a little bit more so you
make a distinction between sex which you
talk about biology ie do you have a
penis or vagina breasts or butt and then
there's the other side which as you say
is more behavior you
clothing whatever so I use then saying
that people's gender and sex can be
misaligned in other words someone can
have a penis but be a matter be a man or
male or what's the right time not really
because I don't think those stereotypes
are so fixed like I think what we're
really just talking about is personality
so you know no I don't actually think
that people are all one thing you know
every single feminine stereotype doesn't
apply to me in some ways they do and in
some ways I will be feminine but in
other ways not you know maybe like girls
can be interested in boys toys and want
to play football and be you know more
interested in trucks than dolls and so
on and so forth
so I think that your personality doesn't
change your body I mean a person can
feel feminine all they want and that
just means sorry I should say a male can
feel feminine all they want but that
doesn't make him not male it's just like
a man who's interested in so-called
feminine things and stereotypically
feminine things like you put on a dress
that doesn't that doesn't actually
change your body right so this is what
I'm trying to get at is what is the
purpose then of separating sex from
gender well could we not just say it's a
feminine man or a tomboy woman odd like
why do we have to separate these two
because I just I see that as kind of
slope towards the trans ideology that
you you were critical of you know this
idea that your biology isn't necessarily
what determines how you how you are in
the world when in fact your logics then
it does sure I mean you could say that's
a feminine man or you could just say
that's just a man and this is just his
personality I mean I don't even know if
we really need to talk about femininity
and masculinity all that much we could
just be like people are different people
I just don't I don't I don't know that
it's all that helpful to you know
discuss these these stereotypes as if
they're inherent although I think I you
know like I do want to clarify that it's
like
I do think that there are differences
between men and women that are connected
to evolution for sure I mean men and
women have different roles in society
and have long had different roles in
society and it sort of makes sense that
they would be engaged in different
activities based on those biological
differences right so but in general I
mean I would just say like like if this
guy likes you know pink and sparkly
dresses then okay like if that makes him
happy then like knock yourself out
go ahead Francis my legs look divine
anyway I didn't think I'd ever say those
words especially going out onto the
Internet anyway moving on I know Megan
I've watched some of your lectures
they've all been very very interesting
you have a particular problem an issue
with the word sis being used especially
to describe women why do you dislike the
word sis because I know a lot of women
though yeah I mean again like I really
just it's totally unnecessary because
supposedly what sis means is that you're
like assigned gender matches your sex
but a I mean I again I don't think
that's applicable to me because I wasn't
I didn't like come out of the womb being
interested in like stilettos an eyeliner
that's sort of part of cultural learning
and socialization and other factors you
know I know women who hate eyeliner does
that mean that they're not simin like
even if they don't identify as
transgender it's sort of like this this
prefix that we're attaching to women
just to say you're a woman who's a
female and that's what a woman is she is
female like we're over complicating this
like there's no fancy definition here
like a woman is an adult human female it
doesn't matter how she feels about her
gender it doesn't matter what her
personality is it doesn't matter what
clothes she likes to wear we don't need
to have that conversation necessarily
it's sort of like
sort of positions women women who are
female ie all women as not the norm like
now it's sort of like a trans woman is
an actual women and women who don't
identify as trans have to add this extra
extra word sis it's a different kind of
women like it's just it's all imaginary
and it's all kind of like gobbledygook
like you know you you you aren't a woman
like we keep insisting and by we I mean
not we at all because I've never
insisted this progressive the trans
activist the liberal is like whatever
you want to call them and some trans
identified people and I mean I should
also add that like not all trans
identified people agree with this crap
right like I know people who call
themselves transsexual who know full
well that they're male but for whatever
reason they feel more comfortable trying
to present as women we've had rows of
doing on the show precisely talk and and
there's a whole spectrum within that as
well like we've had India Willoughby who
is a trans woman and on many things I
think she'd disagree with you but on the
sports issue for example agrees with you
completely right so there's a range of
opinion and this is one of the problems
with the progress of left's ideology is
that it assumes that people of a certain
identity group all think the same which
of course is an incredibly racist sexist
transfer become a phony concept in and
of itself right but so the Syst thing
annoys you for that reason and what
about this is another thing that I've
I've actually made the mistake of I I
heard the word turf being used right and
I looked up the definition which is
trans exclusionary radical feminists and
I assumed that that's what it meant so I
used it to describe a woman who was a
trans exclusionary radical feminist and
a bunch of our viewers and subscribers
freaked out and said that it's a massive
insult so why is that
why is that such a painful word to use
about gender critical feminists um well
I don't think it really makes any sense
because it's applied to all sorts of
people regardless of whether or not they
identify as radical feminists in the
first place I don't know identifies
radical feminists I'm not really super
interested in identifying as anything
these days I don't think that labels are
all that helpful and prefer to just have
conversations about I think but I mean I
am of course a feminist but it's also
like it's not about excluding trans
identified people it's about definitions
and it's about keeping men specifically
out of women's faces so I think what
they actually mean they're just not
being honest when they use these terms
right but they actually mean is that
feminists certain feminists are wanting
to keep women only spaces women only and
so if you're male you can't access again
like a woman's transition house they're
saying you shouldn't be transferred to a
female prison because that's dangerous
that you shouldn't just be allowed to
like walk into a woman's change room and
start getting undressed and it's you
know it's not about keeping for example
females who identify as trans out of
women's faces and it sort of isn't it
though I mean what if what if if you
have a trans man so that's someone who
used to identify or who's biologically
female but has transitioned to male it's
a difficult one but it's someone who was
born a woman born female right and now
dresses and appears to be male for all
intents and purposes they may have
facial hair right what would would you
not want them excluded from a female
only space no I mean if they're female I
don't really care I you know women's
faces are for women and as far as I'm
concerned women who identify as trans
men are so female and you know like the
honest
truth is that like most trans-identified
people don't pass most people in the
world can discern sex pretty easily
that's again part of our like part of
evolutionary biology later we do need to
discern sex so I think there's like a
few people who who can pass so that is
to say like a man who transitioned to be
a woman and people when they see him on
the street actually just as soon as a
woman and vice versa but most people
don't and no I have no interest in
excluding you know women or girls who
identify as boys or women from from
female only spaces and you know turf
really is only used in the pejorative
like its own it's it's it's used as an
insult and an attack in to shut down
conversation it's been used against me
and lots of other women that I know
attach to you know like misogynist terms
and like attach to violence threat it's
like die turf at one of the events that
we held in here in Vancouver in the
winter you know there were these
activists outside would put together
this like cardboard guillotine
and it was like turf step right up
people have vandalized Vancouver rape
relief and women's shelter storefront
which is like a local transition house
here in Vancouver that's woman only so
they're kind of constantly under attack
because they're insistent on not letting
men in to this space we're like women
are escaping horrific violence and abuse
and trying to heal from like sexual
assault and things like that so you know
they they graffiti'd like die on their
storefront you know like it's it can be
used it like really scary ways not
always but but it's certainly not
uncommon and it's just it's used as a
way to attack anyone who asked questions
about or challenges gender identity
ideology legislation policies again
whether or not they identify as radical
feminists whether or not they're
interested in excluding
trans-identified people from anything
like if you just say you know men are
male or you can't change sex then you're
a turf supposedly and how have we got to
this point because it just seems to me
that we've just descended into lunacy
and into chaos where you've said
yourself like people are graffiti on a
rape crisis center how has it come to
this point that's a really good question
and I thought about this a lot and I'm
not entirely sure because it does seem
totally insane and so many people are on
board with it like regular intelligent
people or people who I thought were
regular intelligent people until they
started repeating this nonsense have
gone along with this and act like I'm
some kind of like horrible villain
because I say things like men aren't
women and I'm just like I've had a lot
of trouble figuring out if they're
actually being sincere in their beliefs
when they say things like trans women or
women or if they're just saying it so
they don't get in trouble or if they've
just been told you know this is the
progressive thing to say and think so
unless you're a terrible bigot and a
Nazi then you have to go along with this
and nobody wants to be a Nazi very few
people want to be Nazis in any case so
like I again like I sort of think a lot
of it came out of academia like it's you
know a lot of it is just this weird
theory that got translated somehow into
real life and completely confused and
even the people who support this
ideology so I refer to those people as
trans activists not necessarily because
they're actually trans but because they
push this these ideas you know even even
these people you know when you when you
ask them questions and you try to talk
to them about this ideology what they
say doesn't make any sense and they
can't answer basic questions like again
you know I would always ask like what is
a woman like if you're going to announce
trans women are women what does that
mean what is the word women need
they're like whatever you know they
can't answer so they'll say something
like it's just anyone who identifies as
a woman and I'll say okay so what is it
that you're identifying as and they
can't answer that and then they just get
mad and block you or they call you a
turf but you know you would think that
if it was really really important to
them that you identify a so-called trans
woman as a woman that that would be
because that word actually means
something so it's odd that they keep
insisting that you you say that trans
women are women like repeat after me
trans women are women if they're not
even going to define the term woman and
they won't even explain what it means to
say that a man is a woman you know what
what is that process and again like this
is what I said before like why is it
even important like I just feel like
surely we can treat people with respect
and dignity without lying like can't we
just say you should treat this guy with
respect and dignity even though he isn't
masculine or something like that why do
we have to say that he's a literal
female like who does that help it's not
gonna help his doctor you know what I
mean like there's very good reasons to
understand the differences between men
and women and to understand when
somebody is like a male and somebody is
a female like namely like health reasons
but also in some other reason blossom
hello guys and welcome to my bedroom
aka dormitory Odell Pro crash now we've
got one of our returning sponsors coming
back this week is actually one of our
famous favourite sponsors it is the
wonderful hello fresh and hello fresh a
brilliant because they delivered to your
door freshly prepared ingredients from
scratch which means that you can cook
and look like an absolute Pro and know
what you're doing even though you're
completely useless you get 21 recipes to
choose from from your family favorites
to balanced meals under 600 calories in
fact they're pretty good if you're
single and desperately trying to lose
weight in fact guys I was on a date last
night and I made the recipe which was
spicy sausages sticky Caribbean style
veg and mash
potato and I got to tell you something
their Caribbean starve it was the only
thing getting sticky that night but
doesn't matter we move on and the reason
I love hellofresh is because it's dead
easy to use they deliver straight to
your door
the meals take only 20 minutes or less
to cook so when the ladies come round
they think to themselves well the chat
was dreadful but the food was great and
actually hello first I've got brilliant
deal coming up now where they're gonna
offer you 50% of your first box and then
35% off your next three boxes that's 50%
of your first box and 35% of your next
three boxes I mean that is an absolute
lovely deal if you want to take
advantage of this fantastic offer which
is exclusive to trigonometry fans all
you need to do is go to www.youtube.com
it's three boxes and guys you're going
to look like an absolute professional in
the kitchen basically you're going to
look like me and isn't that what
everyone wants tell me this because it
seems to me like the the thing you're
talking about which is the erosion of
reality of the erosion of the concept of
truth the the indoctrination and the
demand that we all subscribe to things
that we know are not true right that is
something that applies in all sorts of
areas whether it's race whether it's
gender and sex men and women whether
it's the trans issue but the trans issue
for some reason is particularly
vitriolic so we just had Graham Linehan
on the show a week ago and we when we
talk to controversial people all the
time but I don't think we've ever had
the level of nastiness towards him and
towards us that we had after having him
on the show why is this issue so so so
difficult and the people involved in it
why are they so so angry that is a very
good question
I don't understand why people get so
angry about this issue I think part of
it is that if you are a person who is
trans identified and you've been told
over and over and over again by these
activists that you so say your man
identifies a trans woman you've been
told over and over and over again by
these trans activists you're a woman
you're a literal woman and if somebody
missed genders you that's violence and
it's traumatic and you know the only way
that you can accept yourself and to live
a happy life is if others validate your
identity so it's sort of it's such a
strange and unhelpful ideology to me
because it's not about you know you
feeling comfortable with yourself
actually the it's rests wholly on
external validation which is very you
know unstable like you can't control
what other people think and say about
you you can't control if you walk down
the street and somebody reads you as a
man because you look male there's not
really anything you can do about that
but you've been told that you can that
you can control that so I think people
sort of become enraged because I mean a
they've they've been sort of they've
been told that they're a very vulnerable
and marginalized population and that
this misgendering thing is like
traumatic and and triggering and will
actually like destroy your sense of self
but I guess I mean I I just I think all
this lying to people has been really
unhelpful to them right because now they
have this expectation that everyone else
should participate in the lie so I guess
and I mean I I also think a lot of
people have just invested so much into
these politics so they've spent so much
time you know changing their policies in
their organizations and going around the
internet yelling at everybody about
trans women or women and insisting that
we don't misgender them you know
journalistic policies have been changed
and so I think it would be kind of
embarrassed
singing at this point to backtrack you
know they made such a big scene about
the whole thing and tried to vilify all
of us who challenged it practically as
criminals you know like I've seen people
say things like you know it's illegal to
misgender it's like hate speech to say
to call a trans woman male and you know
we've seen women in the UK actually be
you know actually I know women in
Vancouver have been fired from their
jobs over this we've seen people be
taken to court over this now so I don't
know I mean I guess it I don't know I
think it's sort of hard for a lot of
people to admit that maybe they were
wrong especially when they've spent so
much time through banging the drum on
this issue I'm Megan do you see this as
a freedom of speech issue like somebody
can identify as agender but it's it's up
to you where they will if you choose to
follow that you know would you go along
with that or do you think that actually
you know it's it's a correct thing to do
I do see it as a freedom of speech issue
I think that you know if you if you want
to call a trans woman she or her then
you can do that but you don't get to
insist that somebody else do that well
Megan let's we wanted to talk to you
about feminism as well because I think
you know while obviously the trans issue
has become a big one I just I just feel
like we've got bigger things to discuss
more generally anyway as a society and
there's bigger things to talk about but
first can you just explain to us what
feminism is because a lot of people who
don't know the details of it will again
look at the official definition and it's
the belief that men and women are and
shouldn't be treated equally right are
equal should be treated equally but a
lot of the people who observe just like
with the turf thing that is the way that
it's defined and then there's the way
that you perceive it based on
observation and you see all the stuff
like men are trash and all this other
stuff all men are potential rapists like
these are those feminists
- like what is the feminist movement and
why are there like these different
readings of it I mean it's yeah like
it's so tough today because I think so
many people have like wildly different
understandings of what feminism is and
people who identify as as feminists will
see things very differently than other
people identify so like I almost like I
I'm almost inclined to kind of like stop
talking about feminism and again start
talking about like ideas and issues
because I just feel like that's more
productive and for us to understand one
another if we're just talking about
specific issues so talk to us about the
specific issues you as the kind of what
I would say is the same feminists you're
not running around saying all men are
rapists etc what are the issues that in
your opinion women who want to protect
and advance women's rights should be
focusing on at the moment so I think a
key issue here is violence against women
and I think it's interesting because I
think third wave feminists so kind of
like modern mainstream feminists like
whatever you want to call them some
people call them liberal feminists I
usually refer to them as third wave
feminists they seem to have really not
focused on violence against women and to
me that that's one of the biggest most
serious issues facing women around the
world you know things like rape and
domestic abuse and FGM what happens to
women in prostitution for example is
really horrific sex trafficking like
these are major issues you know things
like you know the violence and misogyny
that happens in the porn industry and
the exploitation that happens in the
porn industry these are like
multi-billion dollar industries and
thousands and thousands of women are
impacted by these things and yet we
don't see a lot of mainstream you know
third wave feminists these like young
cool girl feminists who are invested in
like I don't know like the phat
positivity movement or like posing in
their outfits on Instagram
and like trying to argue about their
[ __ ] pronouns it's like these things
aren't important like there are a lot of
really important issues going on in the
world a lot of really horrible things
are happening to women girls everyday
all around the world and and you're
obsessing over your pronouns and whether
or not you're non-binary and trying to
like look sexy on the internet like mmm
I mean sorry France I just want to
finish that issue so you see I think if
if if the public perception was that
that is what feminism is you know that
we could see against violence against
women I think you would have a society
where almost everybody thought they were
a feminist on that definition right but
the polling shows that I think in this
countries like 7% of women identify as
feminists at the last poll nearly I
think it's over half of men said that
they thought that feminism was about not
about hating men but it was it is like
I'm almost like a female supremacy
movement as opposed to a movement for
the protection of women from
discrimination so why is there this
massive gap in in perception versus the
kind of stuff that you're talking about
is it that these work feminists are kind
of ruining feminine yeah well I mean I
think that the kind of feminism that
gets mainstream coverage in the u.s. for
example is is again not really centered
around these issues that I believe to be
really important and that it should be
centered around I do think that there
has been kind of like a lot of casual
like man-hating and feminism I guess
these women think is like funny or cool
and it doesn't you know it doesn't
necessarily offend me unless it actually
is offensive but for the most part it
sort of jokey I just find it kind of
like stupid and childish and boring like
all this like male tears things thing
like it's like I don't like I also like
I don't like this idea where we go
around telling other people to shut up
like I don't like seeing other femme
being like you're a man sit down you
have no say in this because I just don't
I don't agree with that like I kind of
think everybody has a say I think
everybody should participate in the
conversation and that doesn't mean that
I think you know there aren't some
spaces that could or should just be for
women to talk about issues particularly
impacting women but I mean you you see
on Twitter and on Facebook like social
media all the time it's like oh you're a
man so like you have privilege and you
don't get to speak and I mean people do
the same things in different ways
depending on your your so-called
identity so it's like oh well you're a
your assist woman so you need to sit
down and shut up like you're white so
you need to sit down and shut up and
that's just like a really unproductive
obviously lady to engage in discussion
and it prevents us from learning and
from understanding each other but I mean
this plays into all sorts of other
issues that we could get into which is
that I don't think that a lot of people
want to understand each other anymore I
think they just want to create divisions
and then talk within their own little
bubbles but yeah I guess I I sort of
lost track of your original question but
actually you you've you've veered into a
very interesting subject which is you
think that people don't want to
understand each other no it doesn't seem
like they do like it seems like people
want their tribes you know people want
to only talk within their ideological
and political bubbles and they get
really upset and triggered and offended
even to be exposed to other ideas and I
find it really troubling but I also
don't relate to that at all because I
really enjoy talking to people who
aren't like me I enjoy talking to all
sorts of people and I find it really
boring to sort of either just for me to
be just kind of preaching to the choir
or for me to be just reading the same
takes over and over and over again it's
like okay got it like I know that you
think this I want something new I want
to you know learn something
I want to be challenged in my thinking
and yeah I mean people people on the
Left I talk a lot about people on the
left because that sort of where I've
been engaged for years and years and
years you know I haven't been involved
and right when the circles much so I
can't necessarily that so maybe they do
this too but it seems to me that it's
it's particularly progressives and the
left and liberals I think the right do
it too as well maybe sorry to interrupt
like whenever we put out a video that is
with like a left-wing person the
right-wing get triggered and like
downvoted before they've watched it and
like it's put loads of comments before
they've watched it and then whenever we
put a video by a right-wing person
they're the left and like than the left
come and do the same thing so I think
everybody's pronto but I would say the
left pioneered it mmm yeah I mean it
just seems like people sort of want
comfort over challenges and and they
don't want to develop an understanding
of people who are different than them
which i think is is troubling in a lot
of ways because supposedly like we as a
society want to be reaching towards I
tolerate diversity inclusion these kinds
of concepts that we hear about all the
time but don't actively actually promote
you know nobody wants diversity of
thought people want the kind of
diversity that shit's a particular mold
you know I feel like that happens to me
a lot where people have sort of put me
in this box and they want me to stay in
this box and if I step outside of the
box so like if I talk to people that
they don't like or you know people that
aren't feminists or people that aren't
left-wing then they kind of freak out
like people seem really triggered by
that and they you know got angry at me
and are like oh well I guess you're not
a feminist anymore I guess you're a
right-winger now because you had a
conversation with this like right-wing
guy and you seem to get along with him
and I'm like well yeah like he's a nice
like why do I have to be mean to
somebody just
like it's because they're evil making
now what do you think now what you
taught some light as constants if it's
very interesting but what do you think
is gonna be the end game if we keep in
our own little bubbles and don't discuss
and don't share ideas what do you think
is going to happen to society as a
result of that I think things will just
get worse I mean I empathy is an
incredibly important thing we I think
that what we're doing in terms of
staying in our little bubble is creating
these divisions in terms of this kind of
tribalism in terms of you know vilifying
people who are different than us
vilifying people who simply don't agree
with all of our political opinions but
if what we're doing actually is we're
dehumanizing people so we're not
treating and approaching and engaging
with people as though they're full
complex human beings and most people are
full complex human beings most people
are in fact not left or right most
people are kind of like a political or
somewhere in between or maybe they'll
hold some views that might fit with the
left-wing view and some other views that
might fit with the right-wing view I
mean people are just way more
complicated than this and if we turn
everybody who isn't just like us into
our enemy and dehumanize them I think I
think it's really dangerous I think that
that's where we get into justifying
violence and things like that and we'll
see this on the far you know kind of
extreme left with like groups like and
Aoife and things like that and I've seen
that in terms of behavior towards me
where people threaten me with violence
and death because they've decided that
I'm this horrible person because I say
that trans women are male or because I
say you can't change sex or because I'm
trying to protect women's sex based
rights but in order to avoid engaging
with me and or in order to avoid
humanizing me they turn yeah they turned
me into this bad inhuman person and then
it makes it okay for them to threaten me
with violence and that's really scary
you know it's not
okay to threaten anybody with violence I
don't care how much you disagree with
them I don't care how bad you've decided
they are that person's a human being you
don't get to go around killing people
because you disagree with them and
that's you know I see those
justifications from people nowadays I
mean it's not it's not necessarily new
but it's sort of like newly shocking to
me that people who claim to be
open-minded people who are pushing for
inclusivity and diversity are also
justifying or very least not speaking
out against these violent threats or in
fact actual real violence against you
know political enemies people that
they've decided our enemies in any case
it's like you've never even had a
conversation with this person anyway you
probably even never read the article
that you're pissed about you probably
never even listened to a word that
they've said and you've just decided
because your your your group your social
circle your political circle or whatever
has informed you that this person is
like a fascist or whatever word you like
are using even though it has no real
meaning anymore
like that this person you know deserves
to be jailed or or punched or whatever
hello guys and welcome to my bedroom aka
Castillo dos EXO now we've got a brand
new sponsor for this week and it's
something a little bit different he goes
by the name of George Marriott's and
he's a singer-songwriter from London at
least that's what it says on the tinder
bio and George is bait I call him George
Wright because he's a mate obviously
he's best known for his innovative
approach to rock music writing daring
tracks with poignant lyrics oh yeah
something for the men and the ladies and
fat guys but because we're nice people
here at trigonometry we're gonna give
you a little sneak preview of these new
single your mind here we go
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
if you like Georgians music and you want
to find out more about it go to
www.osho.com/copyright osho is a topic
of pornography because i bet you only
because but you know we joke about
pornography it's ubiquitous you know if
you look you know a website like pornhub
it's got you know billions of hits every
year but why do you think it's so
dangerous in particular for women and
also its effect on young men as well
yeah I mean I think as you as you say
like I think that it is really bad for
for women not just for the women who are
in the porn films but for you know women
who are you know having sex with men
who've been raised on porn and I think
it's really bad for men I think it sort
of gives it teaches men untrue things
about sex and women and about men also
the the reality of porn and anybody
who's seen porn knows that it's
degrading the women you know maybe
there's some porn here and there that is
integrating two women but I think that
the vast majority is degrading to women
a lot of it is violent a lot of it is
using misogynist and really racist
language it so I mean pornography is
overtly racist and the way that it's
categorized even but there's also a lot
of like racist slurs that we hear in
pornography and so I really I think that
it sort of normalizes the idea that
violence is sexy and that women want to
be degraded that women want to be choked
that women want you know five guys to
come in her face I think most women
don't enjoy that
like it's just this is this is what I
you know and I also sort of think I
think it gives men who watch porn
he sort of I'm trying to think of how to
explain this you know I know of men or I
know of women who've had boyfriends or
partners who like can no longer get it
up without pornography you can't like
come from regular sex with regular women
because they've been watching kind of
more and more extreme pornography and so
they have a climate eyes themselves to
this new thing so I think you know like
I sort of wonder why men don't worry
about that themselves and you know I
think it trains men honestly to be bad
in bed like if you're learning about sex
and what women enjoy from pornography
you're really not at all learning no
genuinely it is very misleading I think
we joke about it but that is just you
you're not wrong there for sure all
right but I guess I suppose the
counter-argument might be well these are
consenting adults engaging in you know
legal activity what's you know who are
we to interfere kind of the libertarian
argument I suppose would you make of
that well I think that that conversation
is more complicated than just consent
versus non consent because I think that
obviously like a lot of women and girls
who do pornography are doing it because
they feel they have no other choice
there's also like a lot of drug
addiction and mental health issues and
abuse that's going on in pornography
there's you know there's information
that shows that a lot of the girls in
pornography have abusive pasts I think
that it's possible to be kind of groomed
into these industries if you have like a
history of sexual abuse and you sort of
normalize that obviously if you're
you know addicted and struggling with
other mental health issues I'm not sure
that the the consent conversation should
just be limited to whether or not you
said yes or no you know if you're
vulnerable then there's all sorts of
reasons that you might agree to do
something that is exploitative but I am
NOT argument Megan sorry to interrupt
just I'll give you plenty of time to
finish I just want to interject this
here the the argument that well these
people feel like they have no other
choice I mean the argument could be made
about any job you know people hate
working in a call center and you could
say working for a very low paid very
unpleasant job is something that you
know you don't have a choice because
again you could have had an abusive past
and therefore you unable to get a better
job like all of this stuff is still you
know human beings aren't perfect none of
us are none of us have a perfect history
a lot of the decisions that we make are
based on trauma you know whatever
experiences we might have had so I
suppose I'm what I'm saying all I'm
saying is that argument can be made
about lots of jobs not just pornography
right sure I mean I think that we can or
should be able to agree that sex is
particularly intimate so having sex if
somebody is not the same as for example
serving them a cup of coffee or selling
them a pair of running shoes and I think
that like this is something else that I
am actually pretty troubled about in
terms of our society and I think that
liberals have sort of played a large
part in pushing this thing that pretends
like sex isn't an intimate and that sex
isn't kind of like a special thing and
I'm not like I feel like I have to be
defensive when I say they'd be like I'm
not religious you know like I came I was
raised like a very anti religion
household you know like I am I've you
know I don't think I even knew anybody
who was religious until I was an adult
like I just wasn't exposed to
Christianity or any kind of organized
religion at all but like I sort of feel
resentful because I feel like third wave
feminism taught me that
should be having sex like men so that it
should be that sex should mean nothing
and that you shouldn't you know like
have a relationship with somebody who
you have sex with and I'm not saying
that in order to sex you have sex you
should be in a relationship with them
like that's not being my history at all
and I think it's perfectly fine to have
sex with people that you're not in a
relationship with but I think that it's
weird to try to force yourself to
pretend that it doesn't matter like that
that other human that you're having sex
with doesn't matter that their feelings
don't matter that your feelings don't
matter and that there's not something
kind of like deeper and more intimate
going on and I think that things like
pornography and prostitution teach us
that this other person isn't a full
human being that it's just a body that
you're using for your own pleasure and I
think that's healthy for any party
involved I again I just think it's kind
of dehumanizing and you know we know
that you know having sex with somebody
like if somebody's like penetrating your
body that's that's different that's
different that's gonna have a bigger
impact on you then you know like going
to the office even though going to the
office can sometimes be a degrading or
demoralizing experience it can certainly
make you miserable it certainly made me
miserable when I had to go to work and
it's it's not the same as you know ready
gang-raped or something like that right
like Oh having gang sex
consensually yeah yeah no I think you're
right and the point that you make about
separating sex from emotion and and to
some extent from relationship I do think
that's part of it as well because you
know if you if you understand basic
evolutionary psychology the sex is a way
particularly for women to to bond with
the man and to get him to stick around
and bring up the children that would
normally have resulted from the sex so I
think you're right that that that kind
of
attempt to just pretend that everything
is transactional in this kind of and
free from anything like that I yet it's
not working yeah and I mean I just I
feel like I spent a lot of time when I
was younger you know like when I was
like 19 20 or whatever trying to shut
down those emotions because I thought
that's what it meant to be like an
empowered liberated woman is to be able
to have sex without feelings and without
getting attached and you know it took me
years to be like oh no that wasn't a
good message why why am I trying to
force myself like I do have feelings
about this like I am attached to this
person and there's nothing wrong with
that like that doesn't make me weaker
not sexually liberated or not feminist
like it's just such a really inhumane
backwards message and do you think it
goes back to the idea that we were
talking about before that there's no
that the Liberals would say well there's
no difference between the genders a
woman could go out and just have sex
with a man and feel absolutely nothing
just like an inverted commas a man would
do totally like it's like this idea that
for a woman to be really liberated that
she has to behave like men and I'm
saying like men in quotations because I
don't think that's how all men behave
but you know that that's sort of a
stereotype that may be true for some men
but it still is a stereotype then the
last that like all men just have sex
without feeling and without getting
attached and you know want to go like
have sex with a bunch of women random
women all the time like a new woman
every night or whatever but it's yeah I
think that it really it was pushed on me
and I and I tried to do this again when
I was younger that it's like I should I
should act like a man and I should be
able to do everything that a man can do
and that's what's going to make me feel
free and and empowered and and it's not
true and I mean yeah I do think that
that message was pushed by kind of
modern feminists and modern feminism you
could say and what do you think of this
argument that Paul
is changed what we expect from women's
bodies the point of the porn off'
occasion of women's bodies that we
expect them now to have a certain type
of you know leg breast but at whatever
do you think that that has impacted on
society as a whole
yeah I mean I think that young women
have normalized objectification in a
massive way and we'll see that in the
way that they present themselves online
on Instagram for example you know like
and we see that in that it's become
really nor the norm for young women you
know teenage girls to send nude
cornified photos to these idiot boys who
don't deserve these photos and you know
and that's I mean that's dangerous to
these girls in a lot of ways not least
of which being that these photos are so
often leaked and then there's nude
photos of them all over the internet and
they can't get rid of them but it's also
like you know you don't have to do that
to get a boy to like you like that's
what girls think that they have to do to
get someone interested in them and what
these girls want is a relationship like
they I I'm gonna sound like a sexist now
but oh well I think it's like what these
girls want is for that boy to be her
boyfriend and to treat her with respect
and to love her and I don't think that
sending a guy like a poorni photo of
yourself is going to achieve that like I
think that you should be trying to like
get to know people
obviously there's attraction to like I
am not so wholesome like you're like
attracted to people and you want have
sex with them and sometimes those are
people who like you maybe you like
personalities that much but like we're
not really girls aren't being honest
about what they want and they're doing
the thing that the boy wants them to do
and that's an exploitative thing like I
don't I think that there's a problem
with like boys and men pushing for nudes
of course also but the fact that women
are just like volunteering this stuff
like it's a normal thing and sort of
that they feel like they have to like
sex up the photos that they're
on Instagram so that you know they'll
feel validated and liked and loved I
mean that's not that's not a good way to
build confidence or to feel validated I
mean so like so a bunch of like random
dudes who know nothing about you who
don't care about you who don't know
anything about your personality who
don't like you for who you are someone
and so forth are like clicking like on
your photo and like wanting to [ __ ] you
I mean is that I don't think that's a
way to build confidence in the long term
building confidence is about like
achievement and skills and getting to
know yourself and like feeling good
about your abilities and liking yourself
and you know I I just don't think it's
I certainly don't think that it's
helpful for for girls and women but I
mean it sounds to me almost like the
modern feminism that you're talking
about has actually undermined the
achievements of previous waves of
feminism and we're now going to end up
circling back to kind of traditional
gender roles eventually when when we've
realized we've gone too far in either
direction do you see that happening
people kind of almost a clamor to from
women to be women and you for men to be
men as that did you see that happening
um not necessarily with people that I
know I mean that may be happening in
other circles I mean it's not I'm not
necessarily calling for a return to
traditional gender roles I just but I do
think that modern feminism took things
too far you could say to the point where
I see it as a backlash I see it as a
backlash against second wave feminism
you know for to what like the
suffragettes fought for what the women
in the 60s and 70s fought for and it's a
real I mean I see it as sort of more
male centered than anything else to be
honest like I don't see this the this
modern version of feminism is really
being very helpful to two women and
you know we can see this in all sorts of
ways but particularly through this idea
that you know pornography and
prostitution can be empowering for women
that objectification is empowering for
women again that women should be able to
like have sex like men but and then also
through this like trans ideology which
which also came from third wave feminism
has been pushed by third wave feminism
in any case that a man a man can be a
woman and there's no such thing as a
woman and it's offensive to say that a
woman is female and so on and so forth
so I don't know if I'd yeah I think that
there's a there's a lot of lying to one
another that's based on ideological
preferences over the truth and we've
sort of been prevented from having
truthful honest conversations because
actually sometimes the truth let you
know the truth has been defined as
offensive in so many ways and so you
know when I try to have these
conversations sometimes I though they're
feminist you know I think I'm positioned
as being kind of sexist or aggressive
and it's like I'm just trying to be real
and and get to the truth here and have
honest conversations and you know I'm
not I I don't know why we can't just
talk about this stuff I mean it doesn't
even mean that one of us is is right or
wrong necessarily but I would like to
have a conversation and I to me it's
just really important to be authentic
and to be myself and if that means that
like I'm a bad feminist then I guess so
be it because I don't I don't want to
lie I don't want to be somebody that I'm
not
no absolutely it just seems to me like
looking at this sort of third and fourth
wave feminism that the mental gymnastics
sometimes that they perform in order to
justify their arguments you know like
you know I'd be saying things like you
know if you're a sex worker it somehow
empowering when the reality is if any of
us had daughters male or female and you
are some dude would you like them to be
a sex worker invariably they would go
hell no probably again why have we got
to this point where someone can propose
this argument and we all know this is
clearly nonsense but some
how its seen is panic it's true I mean
it's we're all just kind of lying to
each other and and like nodding along we
all know that you know no woman wants to
be in prostitution for the most part I
mean it's not an ideal for any girl or
woman to be having sex with random
strangers who don't respect them day in
and day out no one wants to do that like
most women in prostitution are doing it
because they have no other choice and
sure there are some women who choose it
maybe there even some women who like it
but that's a minority and you know again
like there there is a reality that like
if you listen to what women in
prostitution say if you listen to their
stories there is often a long history of
sexual abuse and and grooming towards
towards that role and you know coercion
manipulation sometimes it's more overt
sometimes more subtle but either way we
know that this industry is not an
industry that respects women and girls
you know that it's like a pretty violent
dangerous exploitative industry and like
you say we know that if it was our
daughter we wouldn't want her to be
doing that and we have to ask ourselves
why that is mm-hmm now it's a very good
point ma'am we're out of time
unfortunately so we've got just one more
question for you
and the question we always finish is
what is the one thing that we're not
talking about as a society that we
really should be I don't know if there's
a one thing but I mean I really want to
have more conversations about free
speech and I know that a lot of people
are talking about free speech but I will
say that on the left and leftist circles
we are not talking about free speech
we're not advocating for free speech and
in fact I think that in many ways we've
rejected free speech as an important
value in a Democratic Society I think we
need to be having more open
conversations more authentic
conversations so yeah I mean I can't say
that's a one thing for society but
that's something that's really important
to me that I've been trying to push for
and getting a lot of
pushback against that unfortunately from
from some of those around me yeah well
that's no surprise we have we have some
similar experiences on that front as
well
manga but thank you so much if people
want to follow your work where do they
go for all of that well unfortunately
not on Twitter but I'm on I'm on
Instagram Megan Emily Murphy I'm a
public Facebook page feminist crank calm
is my website and the same drugs is my
You Tube show slash podcast so find me
everywhere but Twitter it sounds great
well Meghan thank you so much for coming
on the show and thank you all for
watching we will see you very very soon
with a live stream or another brilliant
interview like this one take care enjoy
the recipe evening see you soon guys
thanks for watching guys as always
subscribe to the YouTube channel click
the bell button the next to subscribe
button so you get notified when a video
comes out and follow us on all the
social media at trigger pod and also
leave us a nice review on iTunes and
spread the word